[Music]
my name is maya gray and i have a
youtube channel where i express my
creativity and show the love for my
dolls i'm going to be walking you guys
through on how i restored this bratz
campfire felicia doll felicia is from
the campfire line that bratz released in
2005 even though she was very underrated
when she first came out she quickly
became one of the most sought after
dolls to this day felicia pretty much
came with her full outfit she came with
a haircut a missing left brow and lip
chips and she also came with marks on
her body which looked like pens or like
crayons
i'm going to be undressing the doll just
to make it easier for me and just to
wash the clothes as well since they came
very dirty
i'm going to be taking her head off
which is going to help me with cutting
her hair removing what's inside as well
her hair came very chopped it was cut
short i'm just going to be using some
scissors to cut her hair and you want to
make sure that you're cutting down to
the roots pretty much just to get rid of
it and have a clean slate for the new
re-rooted hair
i'm going to be putting her hair into
boiling hot water and this will soften
up her vinyl like the plastic the head
to make it easier for you to plug the
hair out and it also does soften the
glue inside the head
i'm going to be using pointy tweezers to
pretty much pick out the remaining hair
that's inside the head just to make it
cleaner and easier for the reroute and
there's no remaining hair that's going
to be poking out with all of her new
hair
rerouting is pretty much replacing all
of her hair that's already rooted
i'm going to be using saran hair which
is pretty much the same as her factory
hair that she came with and i also
picked out the most similar colors that
i could find just to match it all
exactly
so using a rubric tool i'm going to be
poking each hair into the head pretty
much exactly how they did it in the
factory
i used the base of an exacto knife a
needle and i have a pick to help me out
poke holes into the doll just to make it
easier for the needle and it will also
save you some needles because it will
break if the hole isn't big enough or
the plastic has hardened so starting off
with the reroute i just sectioned out
some hair to make it easier for me
each strand of hair i pretty much wrap
around my finger
i use that to guide the needle and guide
the hair into the needle i used my pick
to create the bigger hole into the
doll's head and then after that i used
my re-rooting tool to insert the hair
into the doll's head
some of the existing holes might be
already
too big or like already cracked so if
you're using a pick to widen up the
holes just be careful just in case you
might crack a big hole into her head or
crack the plastic even more
so the doll came with some pen marks all
over her body
i'm going to be using some alcohol since
it kind of stained the plastic
she came with chip brows and chip lips
i'm just going to be repainting them
using some acrylic paint and some nail
polish that i have i just use a normal
paint brush typically used for doll
repaints and these are like usually
smaller than normal paint brushes since
it's for detailing
during repainting it's important to have
a steady hand
if there's any mistakes that i've done
with the repainting
i'm going to be using some rubbing
alcohol just to remove some of the
imperfections or like just to clean up
the repainting just a little bit just to
make her eyebrow
more sharp
so with repainting her lips i used nail
polish that was pretty much
clear and i used some eyeshadow that was
pretty similar to her lip color that i
found so it was pretty lucky so i just
mixed the clear nail polish and the
eyeshadow together just to have a paint
consistency
and i just used that to repaint her lips
i pretty much just used a normal washing
detergent for her clothes and used it
with some lukewarm water so i pretty
much just kind of scrunch it up in the
water just making sure all the dirt is
out of it
you can see by the water how dirty the
clothes came in so it was definitely a
good decision to wash them
[Music]
i'm going to be redressing her back into
the clothes that she came with
they are the original clothes from the
campfire line just some pieces missing
[Music]
i'm very happy with this restoration and
i'm happy to have felicia in my dog
collection since she is very sought
after and very loved by a lot of
collectors